The 47 Ronin - Japan’s Greatest Tale of
Vengeance
This tremendous tale of samurai loyalty and
honor goes by several names.
It is usually referred to as the Akō jiken
in Japan, translated as the Akō incident,
or sometimes the Akō vendetta.
It has been featured so prominently in Japanese
literature and kabuki theater that it spawned
its own genre - Chūshingura, or The Treasure
of Loyal Retainers, that only includes fictional
stories based on this historical event.
In the West, we know it as The 47 Ronin - the
story of 47 early 18th-century samurai who
lose their master and embark on an ambitious
journey to avenge the unjust death of their
lord.
The tale first made its way to our parts over
a hundred years after it took place courtesy
of Isaac Titsingh, a Dutch merchant and scholar
who did business with the Tokugawa shogunate
of Japan on behalf of the Dutch East India
Company.
The event was later popularized by British
writer and former diplomat A.B. Mitford who
featured it prominently in his anthology book
Tales of Old Japan.
This has become the definitive version of
the story in the West and the one we will
be mostly relying on today.
Modern scholars opine that, while Mitford
did do plenty of research for his book and
presents a lot of details and descriptions,
he also had a habit of overdramatizing some
of the more climactic parts to make for a
more exciting story.
Even so, today we bring you, as best we know
it, the tale of the 47 ronin.
The Death of Asano Naganori
Our story starts at the very beginning of
the 18th century.
To help you understand it better, we should
quickly present a few concepts about feudal
Japan.
At that time, the country had an emperor,
but his role was mostly symbolic.
The true power was held by the shogun because
he had command over the military.
In 1701, when the events took place, Japan
was almost halfway through the Tokugawa period,
also known as the Edo Period, because that
is where the shogunate established its seat
of power while the emperor was still based
in Kyoto.
Edo is better known today as Tokyo.
Although Higashiyama was the Emperor of Japan
back then, the man actually in charge was
Tokugawa Tsunayoshi, the fifth shogun of the
Tokugawa dynasty.
And the shogun exerted his power throughout
the land with the help of 300 feudal lords
called daimyo.
One of those daimyo (and the one pertinent
to us today) was Asano Naganori, the third
member of the Asano clan to rule over the
Akō Domain.
In 1701, he and another noble named Kamei
Korechika were tasked with organizing a reception
for some of the emperor’s ambassadors visiting
Edo Castle as part of their service known
as sankin kōtai.
Sankin kōtai was a policy developed by the
Tokugawa shoguns to help them keep an eye
on their feudal lords and to minimize their
resources so they didn’t get any funny ideas
about revolting.
Basically, it meant that the daimyo had to
split their time between their own domains
and Edo Castle.
For several months at a time, every feudal
lord took his family and his retainers and
went to live in Edo where he served the shogun
directly.
His family (and, most importantly, his heir)
stayed in Edo whenever the daimyo left to
look after his fiefdom and they were basically
hostages of the shogun to ensure that the
lord behaved himself.
Moreover, the Edo residence of the lord plus
all the tasks he had to perform for the shogun
while he was there were all paid out of his
pocket which meant less money to raise an
army that could be used against the shogun.
Anyway, it was Asano Naganori’s time to
perform his sankin kōtai.
In order for him and Kamei to organize a proper
reception for the imperial ambassadors, they
needed lessons in court etiquette and protocol
from one of the shogun’s high officials
- a man named Kira Yoshinaka who was a kōke,
meaning a master of ceremonies.
Of course, for his services, Kira expected
gifts and monetary compensation.
Kira and the two daimyo did not get along.
We are not sure exactly what the reason was.
Mitford said that the Edo official “was
a man greedy of money” who wasn’t happy
with the “gifts” he received.
Other sources said he was an arrogant man
who treated the two nobles with contempt and
ridicule.
Either way, his actions and attitude became
too much to bear, but it was actually the
other daimyo, Lord Kamei, who first decided
he wanted to kill Kira.
He announced his intention to his retainers
during a meeting, saying that he had made
up his mind and, the following day, he would
strike down Kira after the first insult and
then would suffer the consequences.
His servants had no choice but to accept their
master’s decision, but his councillor looked
for another solution.
He realized that the only way to get through
to the official was with a bribe so he collected
all the money he could and rode off that night
to Kira’s mansion.
There, Kamei’s servant presented him with
a thousand ounces of silver, plus another
hundred for his retainers.
This bribe had a miraculous effect on Kira.
The next day, he apologized to Kamei for his
conduct and, from then on, treated him with
respect.
His behavior towards Asano, however, remained
unchanged.
If anything, it became even worse as Kira
was now angry that the lord from Ako didn’t
follow his fellow nobleman’s example.
For a long time, Asano Naganori took the insults
in silence, but he eventually reached his
limit.
At one point, Kira pointed to his foot and
said that the ribbon of his sock had come
untied and told the lord to bend down and
tie it for him.
Although burning with rage, Asano did this,
but afterwards Kira continued to mock him,
saying that he was a clumsy country boor who
did it improperly.
That was enough.
Asano took out a small sword called a wakizashi
and attacked the official, but only managed
a cut on Kira’s face before guards separated
them.
Even though the injuries were minor, the consequences
were grave.
Although he deserved it, Kira was still a
powerful official of the shogun, not to mention
that any kind of violence was forbidden at
Edo Castle.
Asano Naganori was condemned to commit seppuku,
a ritual suicide by disembowelment.
His death also meant the death of his clan
- his lands and goods were confiscated while
his retainers became ronin, meaning samurai
without masters.
The Revenge Plot
Revenge for Asano’s death had been expressly
forbidden by the shogun, but for some men
this mattered little.
The Ako daimyo had hundreds of retainers,
but 47 of the most loyal banded together with
the intent of seeking vengeance on behalf
of their former master.
Led by Asano’s former principal councillor,
Ōishi Kuranosuke Yoshio, they became the
47 ronin.
Now Kira may have been a corrupt, arrogant,
and reprehensible man, but he was no fool.
He realized that, even with the shogun’s
decree, some of Asano’s former men might
feel duty-bound to seek revenge.
Therefore, he surrounded himself at all times
by a host of guards provided by a daimyo named
Uyesugi Sama who was his father-in-law.
The ronin could have attempted to take on
Kira and his men in open battle.
They were all quite prepared to die for their
vengeance since they realized that, even if
they were successful, they would, most likely,
be executed anyway.
However, what they could not risk was Kira
getting away during the fight as they would
almost certainly get only one shot at it.
Therefore, they needed the Edo official to
get rid of his bodyguards and, for that, they
needed to convince him that there was no threat.
To achieve their goal, the ronin all pretended
to get on with their lives and go their separate
ways.
Like many of the other retainers who once
worked for the Asano clan, they found new
professions - some became merchants, others
became carpenters, some even posed as monks.
Out of them all, Ōishi went to the greatest
lengths to allay Kira’s suspicion.
As Asano’s most trusted servant, he was
also the one the official feared the most
because it was expected of him to seek revenge.
Instead, Ōishi relocated to Kyoto with his
family where he became a drunkard and a womanizer.
He knew he had Kira’s spies on his tail,
watching everything he did and reporting back
to Edo so he had to dedicate himself completely
to this new role, regardless of the shame
it brought upon him.
He would spend his days in bars and brothels,
stumbling drunk through the streets and causing
a scene so everyone would know what had become
of Ōishi, once proud samurai of the Ako daimyo.
The most notorious incident happened with
a man from Satsuma who recognized Ōishi passed
out in the street.
Disgusted with him, he called him “fool
and craven” and “unworthy the name of
a samurai.”
He then kicked and spat on him.
Ōishi accepted everything, but he then went
even further.
His wife, although she knew of her husband’s
plan, could no longer stand the shame.
She begged him to show some restraint, but
this only served to spur him on even further.
He concluded that a man in his position would
likely be abandoned by his family.
Because his wife knew it was all an act, she
did not want to actually leave her husband,
so Ōishi left her and told her to take the
children, too.
Only his eldest, Ōishi Chikara, stayed by
his side, as he was one of the 47 ronin.
And so Ōishi carried on.
Meanwhile, all his actions were reported back
to Kira and, eventually, his dedication paid
off.
After over a year and a half later, the official
started to feel safe again, believing that
Asano’s former samurai had left their past
lives behind them, vengeance and all.
He sent most of his guards back to their lord
and, once again, was only protected by his
own much smaller retinue.
While Ōishi was giving his Oscar-worthy performance,
some of the other ronin did their part by
getting jobs in Edo in anticipation of the
attack.
They observed the layout of Kira’s house,
looked for places to enter and exit, studied
his movements, and gathered information about
his retainers.
They also started smuggling and stockpiling
weapons which they had to do in great secrecy.
As we previously mentioned, not everyone could
just walk around Edo armed to the teeth, not
to mention that it would have surely raised
a few eyebrows if Asano’s former retainers,
who were now supposed to be craftsmen and
merchants, started equipping themselves like
samurai again.
Things were going pretty smoothly and, once
Kira sent his army away and Ōishi was no
longer being spied on, it was all a matter
of waiting for the opportune time…
The Attack on Kira’s Mansion
Almost two years had passed since the death
of Asano Naganori, but on December 14, 1702,
the 47 ronin were ready to avenge their former
master.
It was a cold, snowy day and the wind howled
with fury.
The ronin lurked patiently in the shadows,
waiting for midnight to launch their assault.
The night before, they held one final feast
together as the plan was to turn themselves
in and accept the death sentence that was
sure to come.
Of course, this would be after they chopped
off Kira’s head and delivered it as an offering
to their master’s tomb.
The signal for the attack was the beating
of a drum.
All the ronin also carried a shrill whistle
with them which they would blow if they found
and slain their target.
The samurai had split into two groups.
One was led by Ōishi and would charge through
the front gate while a smaller group led by
his son would cover the side entrance to ensure
that Kira would not slip through their grasp.
They knew that there would be collateral damage.
Killing Kira’s retainers was unavoidable
as they would surely try to protect their
master.
However, Ōishi urged his brethren to avoid
hurting any women, children, old men, and
any other helpless persons they might run
into.
On the night in question, the ronin leader
even sent one of his companions to Kira’s
neighbors to inform them of who they were
and what they intended to do.
The messenger assured the neighbors that they
were neither thieves, nor ruffians, and that
no harm would come to them as long as they
did not try to interfere.
Indeed, the neighbors found these terms perfectly
agreeable and none of them tried to come to
the official’s aid because none of them
liked Kira, in the first place.
At least, that is how he is portrayed in every
retelling of this story.
Some historians indicated that the master
of ceremonies may have been more popular in
real life in his hometown because he helped
develop farmland and build dikes.
With that matter settled, it was finally time
to strike.
Ōishi began beating his drum and the ronin
stormed the house of Kira Yoshinaka.
Ten of the samurai climbed the rooftops, took
out their bows and kept a watch on the courtyard
to make sure nobody escaped to call for reinforcements.
Meanwhile, the frontal assault team led by
Ōishi broke into the main hall where it was
greeted by ten of Kira’s soldiers.
A fight ensued, but the ronin were more prepared
and determined compared to the retainers who
had just been disturbed from their slumber.
Ōishi’s group managed to take down their
opponents without losing a single man.
Meanwhile, Ōishi Chikara and the other ronin
made their way through the garden and were
fighting other guards in the back of the house.
Eventually, the two groups reunited and headed
towards Kira’s private chambers together.
As Ōishi predicted, some of Kira’s men
tried to make a getaway and bring word to
their master’s father-in-law, Uyesugi Sama,
who would have sent a small army to eradicate
the intruders.
However, they were all struck down by the
archers prowling the rooftops.
There would be no help for Kira on that day.
The fight went on until there were only three
of Kira’s retainers left standing, but these
were his best samurai.
They were Kobayashi Hehachi, Waku Handaiyu,
and Shimidzu Ikkaku.
They were all that stood between the ronin
and Kira’s private room, but they proved
to be quite a lot to handle.
The three expert swordsmen defended their
point with fierce intensity and even managed
to drive the ronin back.
Seeing that his men were tired and starting
to lose heart, Ōishi shouted at them with
rage.
They had already forfeited their lives, so
why were they shrinking in their resolution
now?
They should go in there and either kill their
opponents or die trying as fulfilling their
master’s cause was the “noblest ambition
of a retainer.”
He then commanded his son, Chikara, to go
engage the three samurai in combat.
The young man obeyed his father, picked up
a spear and locked weapons with Waku Handaiyu.
Their brawl was too intense to be contained
in just one room and, soon enough, the two
were fighting in the garden.
All seemed lost for the younger Ōishi when
he tripped and fell in the pond.
As Waku was getting ready to deliver a killing
blow, Chikara drew his sword and cut his opponent’s
leg, causing him to fall.
The ronin then managed to get up and kill
Handaiyu before he could retaliate.
When he went inside, Chikara discovered that
the rest of the ronin finally dispatched the
other two swordsmen, as well.
There was nobody left to protect Kira.
The Search for Kira
The ronin opened Kira’s private chambers,
but all they found was young Kira Sahioye,
the kōke’s son.
He wielded a halberd and tried in vain to
defend his position, but he was too weak and
inexperienced to pose a real threat to one
ronin, let alone dozens of them.
He attacked and was wounded, but the samurai
allowed him to flee.
There was only one target they had on their
collective minds so the search started for
Kira Yoshinaka.
The ronin split into several small parties
and completely ransacked the mansion, but
there was no trace of the imperial official.
All they could find were weeping women and
children who, in accordance with Ōishi’s
request, were left alone.
The ronin felt despondent and, at one point,
even contemplated committing suicide then
and there as they feared they had failed their
mission.
However, while going through Kira’s bedroom,
Ōishi felt that his bed was still warm which
meant that he was sleeping in it when the
attack began.
Kira had to be somewhere near, so they started
a new search.
This time around, the samurai were more fortunate.
One of them made the inspired choice to take
down a large picture which was hanging on
the wall.
Behind it, they discovered a secret tunnel
which led outside to a small courtyard where
there was a storage room for firewood and
charcoal.
At the other end of the tunnel, there were
two more guards lying in wait, but they were
no match and were quickly struck down by the
ronin.
Inside the outhouse, the samurai found an
elderly man in his 60s, dressed as a noble.
The man refused to give his name, but the
ronin were convinced they had found Kira Yoshinaka.
Ōishi was able to confirm the identity of
the elderly stranger when he recognized the
scar that his master left him during his attack
that started this whole chain of events.
Despite the ronin’s hatred for this man,
it was trumped by Ōishi’s sense of honor
and respect for the traditions of a samurai.
He actually kneeled down and bowed his head
in deference to Kira, and informed him that
they were the former retainers of Asano Naganori,
there to seek justice for their master.
He then gave the official the chance of a
nobleman’s death by committing seppuku.
According to some versions, Ōishi even produced
the same wakizashi that his master used, but
this may be one of Mitford’s added elements
for dramatic effect.
Either way, Kira had no interest in any kind
of death so he kept begging for mercy.
Unsurprisingly, given all they went through,
this had no effect on the ronin.
Eventually tiring of the old man’s pleas,
Ōishi forced him on his knees and cut off
his head.The ronin collected Kira’s head
in a bucket and prepared to leave, but made
sure to put out all of the lights so as not
to start a fire that might damage the neighbors’
houses.
The Final Road
With their mission accomplished, the 47 ronin
embarked on a new journey to Sengaku-ji in
Takanawa where their master’s grave was
located with the intent of presenting Kira’s
head as an offering and fulfillment of their
duty before turning themselves in.
They had to hurry.
Word of their deed had spread quickly throughout
the town and, when it reached Lord Uyesugi
Sama, he would have surely sent his men to
cut them down.
But they soon discovered that, apart from
him, everyone else was very impressed with
their actions.
It was, after all, what was expected of a
true samurai.
Word even reached a chief daimyo named Matsudaira
Aki, a former superior of the Asano clan,
who was greatly pleased with the ronin and
sent his own guards to ensure their protection
on the road to Takanawa.
When the men reached the palace of the Prince
of Sendai, he, too, was satisfied with their
actions, and invited them to eat, drink and
rest, before continuing on their journey.
And so the 47 ronin reached their destination
safely, performed the offering and said prayers
at their master’s tomb.
Except that the 47 were actually 46.
One of the ronin named Terasaka Kichiemon
had been absent from the procession to the
temple, although what exactly had happened
to him remains somewhat of a mystery.
He didn’t die in the fight.
He also didn’t commit seppuku alongside
the rest of the ronin as he lived to the ripe
old age of 83.
Mitford makes no mention of him in his version
of the events, although subsequent stories
suggest that Terasaka, because he was the
lowest in rank, was dispatched as a messenger
to travel to the Ako domain and tell Asano’s
family of what had happened.
However, some historical documents indicate
that the ronin may have simply fled before
the attack and abandoned the raid altogether,
which is why he wasn’t sentenced to death
like all the others.
This goes against the triumphant, heroic tale
of the 47 ronin, though, and because there
is nothing conclusive to support it, this
part of the story usually gets “forgotten”
in retellings.
As far as the other 46 ronin were concerned,
what they expected to happen, happened.
They were arrested and sentenced to death.
However, because many saw their actions as
righteous and justified, they were not executed
as criminals, but were allowed to commit seppuku.
Afterwards, they were all buried at Sengaku-ji
next to their lord.
The 47th ronin joined them upon his death.
Their graves had become a popular place of
pilgrimage and one of the many people who
came to pay their respects was the same Satsuma
man who once kicked and spat on Ōishi in
the street when he thought the ronin had become
a drunkard unworthy of the name “samurai.”
He apologized for his insult and offered atonement
by taking out a dagger and stabbing himself
in the stomach, dying in front of Ōishi’s
grave.
This wasn’t a unique case.
Mitford also mentions a samurai who, almost
170 years later, committed seppuku before
the grave of Ōishi Chikara because he was
refused entry into a clan.
In modern times, there is a festival at Sengaku
Temple every December 14.
Not as many cases of seppuku nowadays, but
people still turn up to help commemorate the
tale
of
the 47 ronin.